I am about to get buried in concrete.
And while that's happening,
I'm going to explain
everything you need to know
about this substance.
So the first thing that I want
to clear up is the difference
between cement and concrete,
because people often mix these up, okay?
Cement is like the glue.
It's the matrix of stuff.
Oh there, I feel it.
Okay, that feels good.
Now concrete is cement plus aggregate,
so plus gravel and sand.
And this is filling up
really rather quickly.
Cement is the most
important man-made substance
on the planet.
We use more of it than any other
substance apart from water.
Every year, 500 kilograms
of cement are created
for every man, woman, and child on earth.
And that amount of cement
can make two cubic meters
of concrete, which is about
two of these big fishbowls.
This video is sponsored by Wren.
I don't think people realize
just how important concrete is.
So here's another way to think about it.
Every year, we make a certain
weight of goods out of copper,
more out of aluminum,
and then you have glass, asphalt, lime,
iron is a big one for all the steel,
and then there's ceramic and wood.
But by far, the solid
product we make the most of,
is cementitious material,
essentially cement.
We use as much of it as we do
all other materials combined.
And it's easy to see why.
Concrete is liquid rock.
You can pour it into any shape you like.
It's strong and durable and inexpensive.
And it is so easy to produce
that people have been
making a version of it
for thousands of years.
To make primitive cement,
the key ingredient is limestone,
which is basically calcium carbonate.
If you heat it up to around
1,000 degrees Celsius,
that drives off CO2 out of the rock,
leaving calcium oxide, which
is also known as quicklime.
Now if you grind up the calcium
oxide and mix it with water,
you get an exothermic reaction
that creates calcium hydroxide,
which you can pour into a mold.
And over a time, it will
absorb CO2 from the atmosphere,
turning back into calcium
carbonate as the water evaporates.
Now, that's a pretty
good primitive cement.
It's the first way that
people ever made cement,
but there are several drawbacks to it.
I mean, for one thing, you
can't make the molds very big
because otherwise, CO2 can't
penetrate all of the material
and harden it.
Plus, it's not gonna work underwater
where there is no CO2
to harden your mixture.
The Romans discovered the
solution to these problems.
They added volcanic ash called pozzolana
to the crushed limestone
before heating it up.
And they discovered this
cement was much stronger
and much more durable.
They used it
to create the largest
unreinforced concrete dome
in the world, the Pantheon,
which has stood for 2,000 years.
And they built concrete
piers into the sea,
which hardened underwater.
Some of which are still standing today.
I did not expect it to feel this heavy,
like it's already really
weighing down my feet
and making me slightly concerned
about being able to get out.
What I can tell you is that
concrete is about three times
as dense as water.
- Are you able to lift a leg?
I just wanna make sure
that you're not gonna
have like some suction.
- Yeah, okay, I'm gonna try to lift a leg
just to see how bad it's gonna be.
What I like is having
my feet on the bottom
and I'm not sure I can
get them back down there
after I lift it up,
but oh, boy.
Okay, so that was like...
I'm gonna try to lifting
this leg pretty slowly
and I was able to lift it.
- Right.
- So at least up to this
point, I am able to get out.
My fear is that the concrete is so dense
that when it gets up around my chest,
it may apply a lot of pressure,
making it hard to breathe.
Yeah.
- It's like being in a trench
and having it cave in on you.
You cave in your lungs
so you can't breathe,
so that once they contract
and the weight gets against your lungs.
- That's gonna be hard.
- Have you thought about that?
- Well, now that you mention it.
But we do have oxygen
on hand, just in case.
Earlier, I practiced how I
could get out of the bowl
if I'm in trouble.
- Do you feel that's okay?
- That's no problem.
- Okay, great.
(truck signal beeping)
So how did Roman concrete
harden underwater?
And in thick slabs that CO2
couldn't possibly penetrate?
There is a claim that it was
superior to modern concrete.
So, was it?
For centuries, the Roman recipe was lost.
It was only discovered in a book
in a Swiss monastery in the 1400s.
And since then, architects, scientists,
and engineers have been experimenting
with different cement recipes to try
to achieve the best result.
Now it turns out that
that incredible strength,
durability, and ability to set underwater
of the Roman cement,
that came from the pozzolana,
that volcanic ash that was added.
And nearly 2,000 years later,
people discovered that adding
clay or shale to the limestone
before it was crushed and
heated, produced the same effect.
And the reason is that all of
these materials contain silica
and silica totally changes
the chemistry of the cement.
It means that it doesn't need
to dry in order to harden.
In fact, the water
becomes an integral part
of that hardened concrete
so that it actually
achieves maximum strength
when it sets underwater.
- So this is the compressive
cylinder curing room.
We're required to maintain
the concrete samples
in 100% humidity.
So we've chose to submerge
them in water in a lime bath.
- Every time concrete
suppliers pour concrete
on a job site,
they cast sample cylinders of the material
so they can later test it
to ensure it has the strength required.
- So we actually intercept a little bit
of the concrete going
into whatever structure they're pouring:
a slab, a wall.
We'll intercept it into a wheelbarrow,
take the wheelbarrow over
to our testing station,
and start casting these
compressive cylinders.
Every day we're breaking these cylinders,
checking it for strength.
You can see these have been broken today.
- This strength increases over time,
so samples are tested
at 7, 14, and 28 days
when the concrete is said to
have reached full strength.
- So what we do is we list the date
that there will be placed
in the compression machine
on top of every cylinder.
- In reality, it will
continue strengthening
after that.
Samples are placed in a hydraulic press
and then the pressure is
increased on them until they fail.
- All right, ready?
- Yeah, let's do it.
- I'll start loading.
- Sure.
- We want to maintain
around 30 psi per second.
- And it's important to load at that rate.
- Yeah, you don't want to shock it.
You don't want to shock it
by applying too much load too fast.
This middle number is
showing us our strength
in pounds per square inch.
And then the top number,
the big number is showing us the force
of pounds we're applying.
- What are we gonna get
up to, like 7,000 psi?
- 10,000.
So this is gonna be really strong.
- Very strong.
- Okay.
- Yeah.
- It's always fun when we get something
over 10,000 in a free show.
Bang!
- It'll shake this room.
- And it has reinforced concrete walls.
- It's amazingly just like you
can't see anything happening
even under all that pressure.
- It's still holding.
- I know, right?
- Oh, here it goes.
- It's starting to dry.
- Really?
- Here it goes.
- 11,000.
- Mm-hmm.
- Over 11,000 now.
(cement cylinder pops)
Oh yeah!
- It still got a life.
Having it, it didn't even-
- Fun.
(Derek laughs)
- It's my favorite part.
(cement cylinder blows)
- Yeah, that's cool!
- Let's see.
- Yeah, I like that.
- Like the strongest
concrete in the world.
- Well, the strongest concrete
in the world is gonna be
like a lab-only thing.
- In a competition, it
was above 100,000 psi.
- Today, virtually all concrete is made
with a cement formulation
discovered in the 1840s.
It's known as Portland cement,
but the name is really
just a marketing term.
You know, they claimed that the gray color
of the cement would resemble
these very desirable rocks,
which were quarried near the
town of Portland, England.
But the Portland cement was
made by crushing up limestone
and then mixing it with
a certain percentage
of shale or clay to provide the silicates.
And that was all ground
up into a fine powder
and put in a kiln and heated
to very high temperatures.
And what comes out are these
nodules that are really hard.
They're called clinker.
Now, it's suspected that cement chemists
in the past may have
produced clinker by accident
when they overcooked their lime mixtures.
But since this clinker
is so hard to grind down,
they just considered it waste.
But if you do grind it down,
the cement that it
produces is far superior
to basically any other
chemistry we've discovered,
which is why it is so commonly used today.
Now there are lots of compounds
inside Portland cement.
The most common one is
tricalcium silicate.
I'm now feeling incredibly buoyant,
like I am now floating in concrete,
which is pretty ridiculous
because most of my body
is out of the material.
But because it's three
times as dense as water,
you can float just up to your waist.
This is totally unexpected.
I did not expect to be able
to, like, float in concrete.
My feet are off the floor.
That's where my feet are.
- My feet are here and my shoulders are up
and I'm just being pushed up out of this.
Once you have the cement powder,
the other things you need to make concrete
are the aggregates, sand, and gravel.
(quarry blasting)
These are blasted out of a quarry.
Then they're ground up
to be particular sizes.
There are very strict
requirements about the sizes
and shapes of the aggregate,
which is gonna get
poured into the concrete
because, of course, that
will affect the strength
of the concrete that results.
- Yeah, this is a just a
well-grated concrete sand.
The most well-rounded
material helps the contractor
as far as their finishability goes.
- You know when they're running
that trial over that slab,
they want a rounded particle,
not a jagged crushed particle.
- Do you really want
like a spherical sand?
- Around it, yeah,
a spherical sand,
like a river stone,
like a river sand.
Designers on the strip want
to pour concrete elevated.
They want to lighten up
the load of the deck.
We'll incorporate some
lightweight aggregate
in place of this normal weight.
(rocks rattling)
3/8 size.
Typical concrete will weigh
150 pounds per cubic foot,
normal weight.
This gets us about 110
pounds per cubic foot.
- The aggregates are hauled
to the concrete plant
in big trucks.
All right, I'm gonna release the rock,
(hydraulics hissing)
where they're dumped
(rocks rattling)
and then they travel
on big conveyor belts
up into storage piles.
These get loaded into big hoppers
and then weighed out and
poured into the trucks.
- Control operators can open this gate
and drop material into this hopper,
down into the mixer truck below.
This is where the batch
operator's controlling the plant.
Right here in front of our
batch operator, William,
is the actual recipe
that he's gonna dispense
into the concrete mixer.
Each line represents a different
component in the concrete.
That top one there is a 3/4 rock.
We have an intermediate 3/8 rock below it
and there's your sand.
Over here in this column,
he's targeting, for instance, 3/4 rock.
He wants to hit 13,000 pounds
of material for that load.
The computer's gonna try to
hit 13,042 pounds of 3/4 rock.
- So everything's...
- Everything's weighed up-
- Filling up?
- Right now.
- Now if he goes out tolerance
and he overshoots a target,
it's gonna change the red,
a red color.
Up here on this screen,
we're actually showing the holding hopper.
This material he's weighing is directly
above the mixer truck that
just pulled under the plant.
- What about the water, William,
being orange?
- Yeah, we're a little under on that.
- Okay.
- But we can always add little water.
- Yeah.
- We cannot take it away.
All right, I'm gonna take a
look inside the truck here.
(rotary gears whining)
That's what it looks like
down inside a cement truck.
So I was interested to see
what would be the difference
in strength between pure
cement, cement with sand,
and cement with sand and gravel
like the typical concrete
mix that they would make.
So I had them make up
these special cylinders
and test them in the hydraulic press.
You might think that since
pure cement has the most glue,
it would be the strongest.
- Cement's the magic, right?
The glue.
So if we lessen
or lower the amount of
cement per unit volume,
we're gonna have less strength.
- [Derek] But when we tested
the pure cement cylinder,
it fractured a lot as
the load was applied.
(cement cylinder pops)
Is that it?
- No.
- Not officially.
- Looks like it keep going.
It can take some more pressure.
What?
(cement cylinder pops)
- 8,000 psi,
now it failed.
- Now, cement plus sand.
(cement cylinder blows)
9,163 psi
- Again.
Edit the prediction.
Oh, my prediction was based
on the strength it was two weeks ago,
which we have here.
We got 14 days of 6,600.
So, you know, reason would
be it'd probably break
another 1000 psi above that,
but it definitely gained a lot.
- And finally, cement
plus sand and gravel.
This is the normal concrete mix.
(cement cylinder pops)
Is that it?
No?
- A part of it.
(glass shatters)
- Whoa!
Okay, so that's it.
- That's it.
- We'll take it.
(cement cylinder blows)
- So it did fail at 8,300.
Okay.
I was surprised to see that
all the cylinders broke
under about the same pressure.
I think, to me, really interesting
that you could have all
of that cement, right?
But you don't get appreciably...
- Right.
- Stronger than like this
or that.
Cement is the most
expensive part of concrete.
So if you can get away
with reducing it down
to 30% in the mix
and still get the same
strength characteristics,
well then you should definitely do that.
The other thing that was
interesting was pure cement seemed
to flake and chip more as it was loaded.
So it seemed like adding the aggregate
actually helped the sample cohere
and stay together even
under all that load.
(cement cylinder blows)
So was Roman concrete
superior to modern concrete?
Well, the answer is no in short.
I mean there were some
surprising advantages
that Roman concrete had.
For example,
it was actually less well-mixed
than modern concrete.
So there were little blocks
of undissolved calcium oxide
or quicklime that remained
inside Roman concrete.
And then what happened is
when the concrete cracked
and water got in there,
it would dissolve that calcium oxide,
forming calcium hydroxide,
and then you would get the new
growth of calcium carbonate.
So Roman concrete was
actually self-healing.
That's kind of a fascinating advantage.
But I would say by and large, you know,
when we look back at the Roman structures,
we only see the ones that
have survived to this day.
So there is a survivor bias.
And finally, there's the issue of cost.
We could make very strong concretes
that could last an incredibly long time
but we choose not to
because it's just cheaper
and we don't expect our
buildings to last that long.
Before the concrete goes out on site,
they have to make sure
it's the right consistency
for the customer;
not too dry and not too runny.
This can be adjusted with water
but you don't really wanna do that
because that can also affect the strength.
So here, they use modern
chemicals like superplasticizers.
- Up here on the top left,
you have our dispensing units
for all our chemical add mixtures.
- And that's what they're adding now
of superplasticizer.
It makes the concrete easier
to work and spread around
without really changing the
water content very much.
To check that the consistency is right,
they perform something called
a slump test or spread test.
- We're gonna fill the cone
to the top nice and level,
and we're gonna pull that metal cone off.
Measure the distance it
travels on the board.
- The concrete they're pouring on me
should have a spread of 27 inches.
- We're gonna measure it both sides.
(crew member cheering)
Right on a 27 on that one.
- Yeah.
- And go this way,
right on a 27 on that one.
- So why is it so important
that you got the right
consistency of concrete?
- You don't want it too dry.
You want it wet enough to flow
and fill up whatever container
you're trying to fill,
in this case, the sphere with you in it.
- So the question you're
probably wondering is,
how long can I stay in here
before the concrete hardens?
The usual answer is about
four hours without agitation.
And that's why when you
see concrete trucks driving
down the road, that drum has to be turning
to keep the concrete agitated
and prevent it from setting up.
But what happens if the truck breaks down
or there's a traffic
jam or something breaks,
then, at times, concrete
does harden inside the drum
of these trucks and that
is a terrible outcome.
But there is one thing you can do
to slow the concrete down from setting
and that is to add some
regular pop like Coke.
The sugars inside this coke
actually prevent the setting
up process from happening
and that can buy you a few hours.
So apparently these truck drivers,
they drive around with a
few two-liter bottles of pop
inside their cab
and so they can dump it in
their load if they have to
to prevent it from setting up.
So hopefully that means
I'll get out okay too.
But how does concrete actually harden?
Well, you have the dry
mixture of gravel, sand,
and cement powder and then you add water.
The water starts dissolving
the cement powder grains,
so ions enter solution,
and some of those ions
are calcium hydroxide.
So that's what makes concrete
a very basic solution.
What do you see?
- We're approaching 12, 11.8.
- So the pH of concrete
can get up to 12 or 13.
The pH of this is 11.8 and
that's incredibly basic,
which means if it's on your
skin, if it's on your body,
it can be dissolving your skin and cells.
Being buried in concrete
is sort of like jumping
in a bath of bleach.
And that's why I'm
actually wearing a dry suit
and some latex gloves.
Yeah, it's not something
you want to try at home.
So do not try swimming in concrete.
So now the ions are
dissolved in the solution.
And remember, the most common compound
in cement is tricalcium silicate.
As it reacts with the water,
crystals start to form of
calcium silicate hydrates,
plus other hydrate minerals.
And all these crystals grow
and become interlocking,
causing the concrete to harden.
Note that the water is essential
to the formation of these crystals.
So water is not evaporating,
it's not drying out.
It's actually becoming part of
the solid concrete material.
And that's why this chemistry
is called cement hydration.
It's also why freshly poured
concrete should be kept
in as damp an environment as possible.
Las Vegas is so dry they
frequently set up misters
to spray around new concrete
to ensure the humidity was high enough.
One of the things I realized
while making this video is
that limestone, the core
component of cement and concrete,
well it comes from ancient sea life.
Limestone is formed from
the skeletons and shells
of ancient sea organisms
that, you know, died millions
of years ago,
and then all of that got compressed.
And now we use that to
make huge skyscrapers
and, you know, overpasses,
basically every huge
piece of infrastructure,
it's made with concrete.
And so now when you look at
a beautiful city skyline,
what you're really seeing
is ancient marine life.
Skyscrapers are made of seashells.
♪ Skyscrapers are made seashells ♪
- Yeah, this is wild.
This is hilarious.
I like,
I have no words.
- I'm like trying to
push myself down into it
but it's like,
it pushes me up.
Like I'm pushing down into the concrete,
but it's like bop!
I'm getting pushed out of this thing.
I'm just gonna try to
push myself down in here.
Ooh!
Like that is it.
There is no...
- You can use that.
- You cannot get buried in concrete.
Okay?
I'm doing my best right
now to like sink down
and it is not happening.
But I'm gonna use my
arms to push myself in.
(Derek grunts)
(Derek exclaims)
Working against buoyancy.
This is hard.
We were worried about getting me out,
but like I can't stay in.
I'm gonna try to jump in.
Here we go.
That's it.
(crew members laughing)
All right, here we go.
One, two, three.
That's great.
(Derek exclaims)
That feels so good.
I, like, don't wanna get out.
This is so nice.
Has anyone had a time check?
This stuff is not gonna
set up on me, is it?
So as we've seen,
concrete is one of the
most important materials
in the world.
It's made possible most
of the large-scale
infrastructure we rely on,
but it also creates a lot of CO2,
an estimated 8% of the global total.
That is more than the
entire aviation sector.
But together, we can do
something about that.
I would personally like
to offset one month of
your carbon emissions.
And I will do that through
this video sponsor, Wren.
Wren is a website
where you can calculate
your carbon footprint,
see which aspects of your lifestyle
make the biggest contribution,
and learn how to reduce your impact.
And then if you like, you can
offset your carbon footprint
by funding a diverse mix of
carbon reduction projects
like tree planting, mineral weathering,
and rainforest protection.
For the first hundred people to sign up,
I will personally offset your
first month of emissions.
Just click on the link in the description.
Now, I don't think we're
going to solve climate change
using individual action alone.
If you can change your light
bulbs or install solar,
that is great.
But what we really need is
change on a systemic scale.
And that's what I like
about Wren's approach.
They not only plant trees
and protect rainforests,
they also support policy
groups lobbying for change,
like the Clean Air Task Force,
which advocates for new
technologies and policies
to get to a zero-emissions economy.
The way I see it,
there are moneyed interests lobbying
to keep things the way they are.
So we need to band together
through organizations like
Wren to lobby for change.
And if you agree with me,
then I invite you to click
the link in the description
and join me in offsetting
our carbon emissions
and investing in
large-scale systemic change.
So I want to thank Wren
for sponsoring Veritasium,
and I want to thank you for watching.